good morning John so by studying the
traffic patterns of our educational
Channel crash course I can tell that
students are currently freaking out and
watching 20 episodes of crash course
chemistry back to back to back and that
can only mean one thing very soon a
large group of people will be graduating
into the next stage of their lives and
for those people and also other people I
have made this video hello future dead
person I have an uncomfortable truth for
you you are very likely one of the
luckiest and most powerful people who
has ever existed on this planet I almost
certainly do not feel powerful it's
difficult to feel powerful unless you
suddenly have more power than you once
had or have much more power than the
people around you so they don't feel the
power all the time it's probably good
that you don't cuz it might be crippling
but in terms of absolute not relative
power you are basically a god you can
hold the sum of all human knowledge in
the palm of your hand if you've ever
taken a hot shower on a cold day you
have experienced a luxury that the vast
majority of humankind could never even
dream you can write down a thing or make
a video and potentially millions of
people will be affected by it
that's not normal that's that's lots of
power so what's all that power for I'm
not gonna lie to you this is a
complicated time I for example have
absolutely no practical advice for you
or future career is probably going to
look different than any other career
that ever happened ever so so you're
gonna have to be thoughtful and careful
and maybe even a little bit cunning and
by the time you reach retirement age
jobs might not be a thing anymore so
yeah there is one thing that I can
definitely say about the world as it
exists right now
we are at this moment both creating and
solving problems faster than we ever
have before so your job
the only thing anyone can ask of you as
a human is to solve more problems than
you create also take care of yourself
and have a good time
ideally you are very powerful and you
can make your world and yourself better
so do that as for how to do that I've
been thinking a lot about EVE Online Eve
is a massively multiplayer online space
capitalism game that takes place in the
fictional galaxy of New Eden and sprawls
across more than 7800 different star
systems and just like in the real world
every player in EVE decides for
themselves what success is but overall
the culture of a
is one of theft and distrust and
betrayal and greed the developers of Eve
didn't build this into the world that
culture was defined by individual people
taking individual actions and this is
interesting to me because I also live in
a world that was created by the actions
of people obviously you know the
creation of the world also had some
stuff to do with physics but our culture
is just the collective actions and
decisions of people and that culture is
at this point the single most important
factor in the health and sustainability
of our species and we all get to
collectively decide what that culture is
I might feel like we have no control of
this that were at the whims of what has
come before and that were destined to
end up in a cutthroat world of ever
increasing inequality but not if we
decide to not live in that world not if
we choose compassion we collectively
decide what we're gonna live in by being
that world that's the real power you
have it's not your job and it's not your
bank account the power that every human
has every human ever has had it has
nothing to do with immortality or fame
and yet I think that it might be the
most important thing that every person
does and the reason we educate ourselves
and improve ourselves is so that we can
be more effective at making these
positive changes at creating more
solutions than problems because in the
end of your actions are what build our
world so don't take that for granted and
John I'll see you on Tuesday